i like i remember as a kid i like really
did not like japanese food at all
because a lot of japanese cuisine
revolves around you know the natural
flavor of savory you know savoring it
and just bringing out the natural
flavors of the ingredient and me a thai
person being like
there is not enough ingredients in this
dish what sushi sushi what that's that's
just dry ingredients that's rice and
fish what where's the spice where's the
flavor
but yeah three ingredients like you know
rice yeah rice with a bit of vinegar in
it yeah uh fish and wasabi i'm just like
where's the five million spices to go
with it what what you dip it in soy
sauce where's where's the chilies in the
soy sauce what's the kick yeah where's
the kick and uh like like japanese
cuisine was like my least favorite
cuisine because to me there just wasn't
weren't enough like extra spices or
extra ingredients to enhance the flavors
unseasoned sushi
and then as i grew older i'm just like
you as as a gardener i learned to really
appreciate the subtleties in the flavor
of like japanese cuisine where you it
really enhances
um it really enhances like you know the
good ingredients just rice in it it's
just rice
you know
chefs trained for 20 years to get the
perfect rice it's all right
it's all the same
uncle ben's what is this
all right throw a colander yeah
microwave did you
wash this rice
it's a microwave rice right
five minute rice
minute maid rice well i [ __ ] love the
golden rice in those uh microwave
packets though i [ __ ] love that rice
all the they're ready to make ones right
yeah it's so good yeah they do have all
the artificial [ __ ] in it yeah exactly
fast food rice how do we make rice
unhealthy super unhealthy we found a way
yeah honestly like the fast food uh the
the packeted fried rice that you can buy
is actually pretty damn in japan it's
pretty good oh the one that would you
buy the freezer yeah i used to live off
it yeah i was like oh well i made curry
and i don't want to make i didn't have a
rice cooker at the time yeah yeah and i
hated making rice the way that my mom
taught me which was just boil a pan full
of water yes
which sometimes worked sometimes didn't
yeah
but doing it in japan is like
blasphemous i know i know i know but
it's like it's weird because you'd think
that like the first people to adapt an
easier way to do it would be white
people
because they love being lazy that's true
so like you'd think they you'd think
rice cookers would go down like
especially for the uk where we love rice
yeah like we love eating it with curry
so like you'd think too do people in the
uk love rice with curry that's pretty
much it though but that's the only thing
we eat half the time
masala is like every every week that's
true you'd think that we would figure
out like hey these rice cookers aren't
so bad yeah because like i remember
growing up in the uk whenever i'd like
have my pack lunch or whatever it would
be like you'd never make rice for a
packed lunch it's a dinner
[Laughter]
no but like i remember having this
conversation with my mates and they were
like wait you eat rice
every day with every meal and i'm like
yeah yeah like you you have it with
every meal yeah
and they couldn't like wrap their heads
around you bougie [ __ ] yeah you
eat rice with everything everything you
don't take a brace from right i break
from rice you just it's everything i'm
like yeah it's asia it's asian cuisine
you could you literally eat rice within
every with everything i'm sure the
asians are asking the same thing being
like wait we you use bread with
everything you use
every meal is with bread it's bread or
potatoes yeah wait is that it is
carbs on carbs
i mean i think it's i think it's grown a
lot popularity there in the last 10
years especially rice yeah definitely
not when i was growing up but yeah it's
become way more popular like rice based
dishes in general but you know i think
uh i i say finally what talk i'm sorry
yeah yeah but i think there's enough
dishes where people are making them
where a rice cooker
you're peeled by bread makers people
aren't making bread every [ __ ] day
and if those things are [ __ ] massive
yeah right
my little rice cooker is like this big
but the point was before i did this uh i
used to just buy the microwave packets
they're amazing like 300 gram packets
yeah perfect portion tastes great
slap it on the plate you're good to go
yeah
yeah actually think i actually you know
i actually think those
i i also survived without a rice cooker
in university for a long time because
because the microwave packets were good
enough and the problem with a rice
cooker um i find is that rice goes off
so [ __ ] quick so either you like cook
a tiny bit of rice in this massive rice
cooker because i'm asian and of course
like if a mom if if a mom buys you a
rice cooker it's like the biggest
[ __ ] rice cooker you can ever imagine
how many families
there was a humanitarian crisis but it
wasn't for long because ghan had his
rice burger and his mum gave him yeah
yeah because because like my mum my mum
like bought me a rice cooker for
university because that's like that's
like one of the essential pieces of
equipment that you need for university
for every asian kid that the mum
provides of course and they provide you
a rice cooker that could survive a
nuclear winter you know you you yeah you
pretty sure you can like i'm pretty sure
you like hop inside of it survive a
blast yeah right right but the problem
is like i would always cook too much
rice or too little rice right that yeah
i would either like it would be like
either too much for the meal i was
cooking i would have some leftover rice
um or i'd have cooked too much rice and
like the rice just goes off so quickly
even if you put it in the fridge or
something uh because unless you're
this is this is the asian trap right
because with the rice cooker you have to
eat rice every day in order to cook in
order to eat all the rice that you
cooked with the rice cooker right
otherwise it's just gonna go off exactly
um so that's why actually the microwave
packets were just like the perfect
portion yeah for
for like one meal and it was just like a
lot less effort yeah because then you
have to like start experimenting like
you look in your fridge and be like all
right what can the rice go with that i
haven't tried i wonder can you
dehydrate the rice that you've cooked
turn it back into a rice cream is that
possible well i mean uh if you had the
technology i'm asking is it possible
well i mean like i i put it in
no it's like popcorn you don't turn back
quite oh that that form is completely
different though the rice stays the same
i think i think if you took the water
out somehow maybe we could do it
scientists
i mean i'm dehydrated
my family uh actually a lot of japanese
families what they do is if they make
too much rice then you put it into like
small you know like maybe microwave size
packets and then you put it in the
freezer yes yeah that was also what
happened as well yeah but it's like not
the same like the next morning you wake
up and be like you know okay there's
some leftover rice if i don't eat them
my mom's gonna [ __ ] throw a hissy fit
so let's just get it out defrost that
[ __ ] but there was no space in my
freezer to put extra packets of frozen
rice do you know why as a university
what happens when your mom comes over
she brings you eight [ __ ] eight like
tupperware boxes full of takeaway food
and then
then you gotta put it in the freezer and
it just lasts it'll last you the entire
day
takes up the entire [ __ ] thing
because he decided that his he was going
to meal prep like like an entire month
yeah and you're like you're a [ __ ] you
know
like we got to share the freezer where
is my ben and jerry's going where am i
going to put my body i just wanted one
ben and jerry's in here is that too much
to ask
you like start playing tetris with all
the rice packets yeah yeah yeah
no because like my mom would come to
visit me once a month in university and
every month she'd bring like two full
like sainsbury's bags worth of like
takeaway boxes holy [ __ ] and i'm just
like that that is i don't know i don't
know how many people were in your like
were you sharing one fridge with
like a
six or seven or something like that so
at best you get you you have half a
shelf to yourself yeah yeah and then you
have one like a freezer is even smaller
so you had like what two items to put in
the freezer god you must have been hated
they must behave i probably wouldn't
they probably hated you
i would i would i would frustrate it
i'd be like mate you're sharing this
with me yeah that's my real estate or
i'm putting stuff in there dude like you
gotta you gotta say about baiting my
property a little bit i'm like i'm gonna
have to pull a shotgun on that you're
gonna have to you're gonna have to hang
with me here we gotta figure something
out
[Laughter]
oh god what is uh what it's like living
with a southeast asian guy or girl you
know that's that's true whenever their
parents come to visit they just bring a
[ __ ] ton of food i don't know why it's
part of like i thought it's just like an
asian in general it's not is it true
with japanese because i don't i know
it's true like southeast asian and
chinese i know when i was living with i
know when i was living on my own still
uh my aunt used to come over and just
like buy me a [ __ ] ton of food and that
that was when i was sharing house
sharing with two other people and yeah i
was also the [ __ ] that took up like
80 of the freezer so i i knew i knew
very well i'm co-hosting with these
[ __ ] these barbarians
filling up the fridge selflessly
selfishly this is our turn to colonize
we're colonizing one freezer
we're coming for your freezers okay